76 78 80 where the hell is this place
anyway Clea Mars stopped on the sidewalk
and put her hands on her hips looking
down at the doors she just passed she'd
been to some tiny dives in her time that
was true but she'd never had so much
trouble actually finding a place before
sighing she retraced her steps she was
beginning to regret suggesting this
article to her editor as fascinating as
the subject matter promised to be rumors
about the theatre of the observer after
all had been circulating for months
everybody was talking about it but
nobody seemed to know anyone who had
actually attended a performance probably
because no one can find it Clea thought
with a bitter smile she dug a scrap of
paper out of her pocket and studied it
the Sun had just sunk behind the
skyscrapers but there was still enough
light to read her hastily penciled
chicken-scratch 78 and a half Leonard
Street Clea looked up at the numbers
over the doors again there was 78 and
there was 80 right next to it so we're
startled Clea realized that there was
something between the two doors
something she hadn't noticed on her
previous two passes she stepped closer
and squinted into the deepening gloom it
was a narrow fissure like an alley but
only wide enough for a cat to squeeze
through it looked like she frowned
surely a theatre even a small one
couldn't fit in there Clea glanced up
and down the street it was deserted and
getting darker the streetlights hadn't
even flickered to life yet and apart
from the rush of faraway traffic the
immediate area was eerily quiet
cursing herself for opening her big
mouth about this assignment she crept
toward the alley every now and then
glancing up toward the lighted windows
of the surrounding apartment buildings
just to reassure herself that there were
other humans nearby as she approached
the gap between the houses she spotted a
low iron stair railing that had been
virtually invisible from the street
half a dozen steps descended onto a damp
cobblestone path which led up to a flat
black door embedded in a wall
she could just make out the number 78
and a half scrawled on the door and what
appeared to be silver spray paint CLIA
considered her options technically she
didn't have to write this piece there
was certainly no shortage of weird
theatre troupes doing there avant-garde
thing in the city and she could just as
easily write about another one of those
her editor wouldn't care most people who
read their paper weren't trolling for
cutting-edge performance art to check
out anyway they just wanted to know what
hipster bands were playing and where the
cheapest drink specials were still
though this theater of the observer
thing had been nagging at her she had to
admit it she had first heard about it a
little over a month ago from another
writer at the paper who'd heard about it
from the usual friend of a friend in the
void of real information about the place
all kinds of bizarre stories had sprung
up about it the most widely told of
these was that some people who attended
the performances were apparently never
seen again
silly rumors didn't really faze Clea she
figured it was all some sort of viral
marketing hype but she was intrigued
nonetheless and wanted to see firsthand
what all the mystery was about or maybe
she thought to herself I'm so jaded that
I can't wait to see something really new
and different chuckling a little she
hitched up her shoulder bag and began
making her way down the steps she had to
walk sideways until she reached the
bottom but then the narrow alley widened
enough to allow her room to move
normally the stones felt almost squishy
beneath her feet and she wrinkled her
nose at the thick smell of mold and
urine that assaulted her senses she
would have to take a nice hot shower
when she got home from this little
adventure the doorknob felt slick under
her hand and she nearly retched as she
turned it Jesus she knew these troops
were hurting for money but it didn't
cost anything to be cleaned at it her
fingers slipped off the metal and she
wiped them on her jacket the door was
locked
so what now she noticed a peephole in
the door and wondered if someone was
watching her through it the thought made
her arms prickle with gooseflesh and
then she chided herself this was a
public theater right so what was she
getting all freaked out about but that
thought led to another if this was
indeed a public theater where was
everybody maybe they were all already
inside she told herself maybe she was
late or maybe she was too early the
anonymous source on the phone had told
her to go to the theater at 6:00 but
maybe he'd been mistaken in fact now
that she considered it maybe she wasn't
even in the right place
maybe the theater itself was nothing but
one of those urban legends and someone
was playing a joke on her she stood in
the alley trying to breathe through her
mouth the stinking miasma seeming to
thicken around her what if all this was
a prank
she turned and looked behind her it was
too dark to see very well although she
thought the streetlights had finally
come on she didn't see anyone walking by
but this was mostly a residential
neighborhood and it was a weeknight so
that wasn't terribly unusual still it
would have made her feel a lot better to
see an old man amble by walking his dog
but there was no one Clea turned back to
the door was there a flicker of movement
or light behind the people she couldn't
be sure her heartbeat suddenly seemed
very loud in her ears for Christ's sake
she thought don't just stand here like
an idiot all night either knock on the
door and see what's what
or head back to the subway station she
nodded in agreement with her in her
voice she was being stupid just hanging
around
she raised her fist and rapped on the
door for a second nothing happened
but then the knob clicked and the door
swung inward Clea couldn't see anyone
inside it was like a black hole there
was no sound in there at all no music no
crowd noises she stood on the threshold
for almost a full minute staring into
the darkness this isn't the right place
her inner voice informed her better turn
right around and get the hell out of
here
it was certainly sound advice and CLIA
had every intention of following it she
turned to leave but then another voice a
real one stopped her in her tracks are
you here for the show
it asked Clio laughed to herself a
little relieved yes she answered sorry I
didn't know anyone was here she turned
back and looked into the blackness she
still couldn't see anyone where are you
it's so dark come farther inside the
voice said Clio couldn't tell if it was
a man's voice or a woman's there'll be a
light in just a moment leaving the door
opened behind her in case she had to
make a fast getaway she edged forward
into the building
her fingers searched and found walls on
either side of her forming a hallway
only barely wider than the alley had
been the floor beneath her felt hard and
cold through her shoes the mold smell
was weaker here but still present and
mixed with the unpleasant aromas of old
sweat stale perfume and rancid meat she
walked carefully feeling her way hoping
her hands didn't meet anything
unexpected jeez you guys not pay your
electric bill or something she said
trying to sound nonchalant the voice
didn't answer at last Clea could see a
light and she quickened her pace to go
toward it the depth of her relief
startled her perhaps she'd been more
uneasy than she'd realized she turned a
corner and entered another long hallway
the light was coming from an open door
at the end of it almost there
she called in her force jolly way there
was still no response from the voice her
mouth twisting she pushed ahead already
thinking of the first sentence of the
article she was going to write about
this place it appears that the theatre
of the observer is erroneously named as
one must navigate seemingly miles of
pitch-black hallways like a blind person
before one even arrives at anything
resembling a theatre it needed work she
knew but it was a decent start
she was also being presumptuous she had
yet to encounter anything that looked
like a standard theater after all
as she moved along the hall toward the
light she became aware of a series of
what looked like badly rendered
paintings along the walls they were all
done in luminescent paint on black
velvet and Clea thought wryly of those
cheap bullfighter paintings she'd seen
for sale at the flea market
but her smirk died away when she
actually looked at the artwork they were
all of eyes big eyes small eyes some
wide and frightened some narrow and
conniving all were painted in bright
primary hues that seemed to vibrate
against their black settings all seemed
to glare at her was livid intensity as
though they expected her to do something
like it roasted on a spit perhaps Clea
suppressed a shudder then chastised
herself again how could a bunch of
ineptly done paintings upset her so much
they looked as though a bright but
disturbed six-year-old had done them did
the geniuses behind the theater really
think they would scare people so easily
she tried to laugh dismissively but no
sound came out she couldn't help
glancing side long at some of the
paintings as she passed they were a
really creepy she shook herself and
fixed her gaze straight ahead the light
that glowed from behind the door had a
bluish tinge and for a moment she
thought she could see shadows moving
large and ponderous she considered
calling out again to whoever had spoken
to her but she thought better of it
maybe all this was part of the immersion
experience of the show part of its
manufactured mystique this thought made
her feel a little better although a
vague tension remained
finally CLIA passed through the door the
blue light nearly blinding now like the
glow from an alien spacecraft just ahead
she could make out the silhouette of a
balustrade and beyond not the suggestion
of a high ceiling with a dangling
chandelier whose crystals winked lazily
sending beams of refracted sapphire
light in all directions CLIA glanced
around looking for a ticket booth or a
refreshment stand
but the balcony was apparently empty
puzzled she walked to the edge and
placed her hands on the railing it was
fairly dim but she could see rows of
theater seats spread out far below her
and before these a stage with a heavy
blue curtain which was closed as she
squinted down into the darkness she
thought she could see people in some of
the seats no more than a few dozen at
least she wasn't alone here the silence
and emptiness was beginning to get to
her she turned around how would those
people gotten down there and then she
spotted it a small sign pointing
downward on the top of a staircase she
headed toward it thinking the ticket
sales were probably handled downstairs
maybe she'd even come in the wrong
entrance yes she thought that had to be
it that would explain why there was no
one around why she'd ended up on the
balcony her step was lighter as she made
her way down the stairs at the bottom
there was a sharp left turn the blue
light bathed everything giving the scene
a surreal aspect another turn and she
was confronted with row upon row of
theater seats every chair upholstered
and what appeared to be the same blue
fabric as the curtains the seats were a
little shabby but not as worn as she
would have expected given the exterior
of the place and the neighborhood where
it was located she could see the other
patrons a bit better now although none
of them turned to look at her the
nearest person was a thin bearded man
sitting very straight two or three rows
behind clea didn't much like the idea of
sitting near the middle of the theater
but she didn't really want to sit right
on the end either she compromised and
chose a seat two seats over from the
aisle
trying to be as quiet as possible then
settled in and pulled her notebook and
pen from her shoulder bag
after about 15 minutes had passed during
which she'd made a few general notes
about the theater for her article she
began to get restless she looked around
the room surreptitiously thinking she
was doing something wrong for some
reason no one else seemed to have moved
and no one looked bored or impatient
everyone just sat still and stared at
the curtain as though they had all the
time in the world and who knew thought
clea perhaps they did ten more minutes
past clea had begun to doodle a series
of sinister looking eyes in her notebook
next to her scribblings they seemed to
be looking disapprovingly at her so she
scratched them out the sound of her pen
tip very loud in the silent theater
finally the curtains twitched and the
lights got slightly brighter though no
less blue there was a strange sound like
a collective breath being released Clio
leaned forward suddenly attentive her
pen poised between her fingers the
curtains slid open with a whisper there
were no lights shining on the stage
itself but by the glow of the house
lights Clea could see several glints as
of metal or glass as she watched bluish
lights began to flicker on over the
stage at first she wasn't exactly sure
what she was looking at from her vantage
point that glints resolved themselves
into a row of large glass jars of the
type medical specimens were usually kept
in Clea immediately flashed back to her
high school biology class to the shelves
full of similar jars containing pig
fetuses diseased human lungs and any
number of revolting things she wondered
if this was going to be some kind of
freak show deal with two-headed snakes
or kittens with no eyes if so she wasn't
impressed
more lights flickered on now she could
see that the jars contained what looked
like very realistic human heads floating
in a syrupy solution she made a note of
this in her book how very Grand Guignol
she added in the margin she stifled a
yawn then focused her attention on the
stage again the stage was now lit up
like the Vegas Strip the jars clea
noticed were sitting on a long uncovered
table about three feet off the floor
dangling from the bottom of each jar was
a thick electrical cord these cords
snaked back into the darkness behind the
stage and disappeared the smell of
formaldehyde and rotted food began to
reach her nostrils she glanced around
but no one else seemed bothered by the
smell it wasn't bad yet but if it got
worse she might have to go outside and
be sick if she could even make it
outside there was another long silence
as everyone sat there and stared at the
heads Clea shifted in her seat wincing
when it squeaked no one appeared to have
heard then in unison the eyes of all the
heads opened some of the people in the
audience did move then
straining forward a little their
expressions anxious Clea had to admit
the effect of the eye opening had
surprised her
but now she was interested in how the
trick had been achieved the chords must
work the eyes on the fake heads she
figured then decided that the whole
thing would have looked a lot cooler if
the troupe had managed to hide the cords
a little better
she made a note of this then glanced
back up
the head stared into the crowd Clea
could see them all perfectly well now a
row of expertly severed heads realistic
down to the drifting arteries emerging
from the necks some of the heads were
male some were female most were young
but a few were older several races were
represented equal opportunity beheading
very piecey Clea thought and smiled a
little as she wrote this witticism down
in her notebook this was shaping up to
be a fairly amusing article even if the
theater experience itself left something
to be desired when she looked back up
she noticed that the eyes of the heads
were moving left and right slowly
deliberately as if taking in the entire
audience Clea knew the effect was likely
controlled by the electrical cords but
it was still unsettling the heads gazes
wandered back and forth back and forth
when they lid on Clea she felt a chill
that started deep at the bottom of her
spine even though the heads were only
latex and ooze damned if it didn't look
like they were looking right at her
right through her she found herself
leaning forward in her chair like the
others were uncertain of what might
happen next she began to feel a little
dizzy after what seemed an eternity the
eyes passed over her and settled on the
thin bearded man three rows behind her
Clea didn't dare turn to look but she
could feel their stares boring into the
man and she suddenly felt an immense
wave of pity for him
No leave him alone she thought realizing
how crazy it was to be talking to a
bunch of disembodied heads and talking
to them about a man she'd never seen
before in her life her notebooks sat in
her lap momentarily forgotten
suddenly a voice boomed over the
loudspeakers you it said the voice was
the same as the one that had spoken to
her at the entrance an odd vibrating
voice that seemed to contain both male
and female characteristics but then
again sounded of neither the people in
the audience did turn then to see which
one of their number had been singled out
Clea turned to unwillingly hearing her
neck creak a spotlight snapped on blue
and brilliant and shone down upon the
bearded man his face looked round and
terrified there was a pregnant moment
when time seemed to have come to a halt
all of them frozen there in the blue
lights staring at the man with the beard
the man who had been chosen instead of
them and then the scene began to move
again as the man his expression
contorted and steeped in shadow got to
his feet his chair protesting loudly has
his weight left it he stood in the
spotlight his hands folded before him
any time boomed the voice the man looked
as though he might cry he looked around
at the others his eyes pleading his
muscles tensed as though ready to burst
through his skin Clea found that her
earlier sympathy for him had dissipated
and when he looked at her she simply
stared back dispassionate well she
thought crossing her arms do something
the man lowered his head resigned Clea
could see his chest rising and falling
as he breathed deeply in and out five or
six times at last he raised his head his
eyes were glittering and then into the
soaring silence of the theatre the man
opened his mouth and began to sing Clea
stared astonished at the sound that
issued from his throat even though he
had no microphone and looked petrified
his singing voice was like that of an
angel high and resonant seeming to fill
the entire space with its honeyed tones
the crystals on the chandelier seemed to
shiver at the beauty of it
Clea felt a tear travelling down her
cheek and then another she was too
overcome to wipe them away
his song was unfamiliar yet intimate
with her very soul the song of all
humanity the song of the spirit the
words were unintelligible but
unimportant as it reached its climax
spiraling up to the heavens Clea managed
to tear her gaze away from the man and
focus on the other people in the theatre
they were all as transfixed as she some
of them openly weeping the sound of his
voice had opened a window into another
dimension at last the song came to its
conclusion and the man closed his mouth
trapping the sublime sound behind his
lips again no one moved for a long
moment everyone savoring the last echoes
as they died away when the profound
silence had fallen once more the
audience turned back toward the stage
where the heads floated in their jars
the heads blinked in perfect unison and
then moving as one unit they all began
to turn from side to side shaking their
heads as if to say no Clea heard a sharp
intake of breath from the man behind her
that she could not bear to look at him
again he had performed brilliantly the
beauty of his voice surpassing anything
she'd ever heard but apparently this was
still not enough she knew that he had
failed and whatever test had been set
for him and although she was sorry for
him she was also ashamed that he had not
succeeded his failure was somehow the
failure of them all
the spotlight was still trained on him
Clea could see its glow out of the
corner of her eye she heard him cry out
and then start to blubber the earlier
clarity of his song degenerating into
meaningless anguish syllables she
cringed at the sound of it wishing he
could accept his fate with more dignity
as she watched four figures and blue
robes emerged from the wings and swept
up the aisles heading toward the man
their faces were completely covered with
thick cloth veils
but they seemed to have no trouble
seeing where they were going Clea found
that she almost welcomed their coming
and her heart lifted as they neared the
cowering man under the spotlight he
struggled as they grabbed him but his
efforts were clearly no use as the
hooded figures held him fast animal
strength radiating from their bodies
they picked him up by the arms and legs
and carried him over the heads of the
other patrons out toward the aisle
farthest from Clea for a moment she
hopes that they would carry him up to
the stage that she would get to witness
his final humiliation but this was not
to be the man still thrashing and
screaming was taken into the darkness at
the side of the stage Clea 's notebook
had slid off her lap and onto the floor
but she didn't notice it
she was strained forward in her chair
listening for some hint of the man's
fate her every muscle is taut as piano
wire she heard nothing but saw that the
others in the crowd were acting as she
was waiting and listening the heads in
the jars had closed their eyes again and
floated peacefully in their fixed
solution
after a few minutes one of the robed
figures emerged onto the stage footsteps
echoing loudly in the silence in his
hands he carried a large jar identical
to the others and inside the jar the
bearded man's head bobbed gently every
now and then a tiny ribbon of blood
would issue from the fresh cut at the
neck the audience gave a collective sigh
as the new head was set down upon the
table next to the others the robed
figure then glided to the back of the
stage leaned down and picked up a length
of electrical cord which he then
proceeded to fasten to the new jar
somehow crawling beneath the table to do
so the moment the connection was made
the bearded man's eyes opened as did
those of all the other heads the blue
robed figure bowed curtly to the heads
and then to the audience disappearing
into the wings without another sound
Cleo's heart was hammering in her chest
they've got to pick me next she was
thinking I won't fail them the way that
man did she looked around at the others
in the crowd who had now become her
rivals I'm better than any of you they
have to pick me as the eyes of the
disembodied heads began to roam the
audience once more Clea stretched
forward in her seat fighting the urge to
wave her arms in the air for attention
surely they had to see that she was
better didn't they they would have to
see it when their eyes met hers she
pleaded silently with them putting all
the emotion she could muster into her
gaze I'm the one she thought at them I'm
the one you've been looking for but the
eyes passed her by scanning the crowd
for other possibilities Clea slumped
back in her chair feeling the weight of
devastation pressing down upon her this
wasn't right they had to realize that
she was the only one so why didn't they
were they just playing games with her
Clea barely noticed when the heads
focused their attention upon a slim
woman near the front of the theatre as
the spotlight shone down on her the
woman stood and shrugged out of her coat
underneath she wore a spangled red
costume with a flared skirt made from
red and orange feathers delicately she
stepped into the aisle as music began to
play coming from somewhere Clea couldn't
see it was Stravinsky the Firebird sweet
the woman began to dance the sparkles on
her leotard catching the light and
making her shimmer like a candle flame
as she leaped and twirled she was very
good Clea admitted grudgingly to herself
perhaps even better than the man had
been she seemed weightless in the way
she moved the lines of her body like
wisps of smoke upon the air perfect
timing perfect grace she flitted up and
down the aisle and Clea couldn't help
but watch her and be spellbound when the
music was over the dancer stood tall
holding her position breathing hard
beads of sweat twinkling on her skin
the heads considered her in silence
blinking as one and then as Clea had
known they would they indicated that
their answer was again no
the dancers face fell but she took her
rejection much better than the man had
letting herself be led away by the
hooded figures without so much as a word
of regret a few minutes later her
severed head duly appeared in its jar
right next to that of the bearded man
she blinked once then closed her eyes
the other heads followed suit CLIA
leaned forward in her chair again
knowing that this time it would be her
turn but then she saw that the blue
lights over the stage were beginning to
flicker out one by one and the heavy
curtains were slowly drawing closed the
show was over no clea screamed in her
head looking around wildly at the others
in the audience who had begun to gather
up purses and coats no it is it fair it
was supposed to be me next me the others
were getting up out of their seats and
heading toward the aisles none of them
spoke but a few of them smiled at each
other as if in recognition they seemed
like normal people now the hypnosis
which had held them there for the last
hour and a half now completely dissolved
they could have been any audience
leaving any show anywhere in the world
CLIA didn't get out of her seat she
crossed her arms thinking petulantly
that she would sit here all night if she
had to they'd have to give her a chance
then all she had to do was wait and
eventually they would see her and know
that she was the one they wanted she had
to be stubborn shuffling footsteps
sounded behind her first time here
someone whispered she turned her jaw set
who wants to know
the young man behind her smiled his eyes
blinking behind his glasses hey don't
bite my head off I remember the first
time I came here I felt the same way
CLIA scowled at him he was sandy haired
and very tall clad in a gray sweater she
hadn't noticed him in the crowd before
leave me alone
she said his smile didn't falter look he
can't wait here it doesn't work that way
he offered her a hand but she didn't
take it he sighed believe me I've been
coming here for three weeks now you'll
get picked when you get picked that's
just the way it is
finally she relaxed her scowl unfolded
her arms three weeks she asked him yeah
not every night but most nights he
laughed a pleasant sound in the
gathering gloom
I'll get picked eventually I just know
it Clio laughed with him then hitched up
her shoulder bag and got to her feet if
the poor dopes wanted to think he was
the one then let him she wouldn't spoil
his illusions want to walk me out she
said sure he held out his arm and she
hooked her fingers through it are you
going to be back tomorrow he asked of
course
Clea answered and the night after that
and the night after that she thought but
didn't say out loud she smiled at the
young man and let him talk as he led her
up the stairs and out of the theatre
back out into the narrow alley and back
onto the street which was now well
lighted and populated with old men
walking their dogs couples strolling
hand in hand Clea realized that she'd
forgotten her notebook back at the
theatre but then she dismissed it as
unimportant the man beside her was
prattling on and on about something
equally unimportant but Clea smiled and
nodded in all the right places she
thought she might like to take him back
to her apartment perhaps have a few
drinks maybe then things could get a
little serious as the theatre of the
observer was swallowed up by the
darkness behind them Clea tightened her
grip on her new companions hand tomorrow
night was for performance but tonight
she would eliminate some competition
[Applause]
gentlemen calm yourselves there's no
occasion for an uproar be seated again
be seated all of you I beg honor me with
your attention for a moment
senor or tsukino has called me a
murderer he need not repeat the epithet
we've all heard it
some of you gentlemen I did not
recognize the voices so far forgot
yourselves as to suggest that I should
cross swords with Senor or tsukino here
and now or that I should call him out
and fight him at once
gentlemen I brook no suggestions as to
what I should or should not do upon any
point of Honor I permit no man to school
me as to when or to what extent I should
consider myself offended still less what
I fail to resent any question of the
propriety of my ignoring what other men
dare not ignore Senor tsukino has shown
his courage by applying to me before so
many of you a term of such serious
import he can incur no dishonor by
hearing out in silence what I wish to
say before we proceed to a final
settlement as Victor and some score of
duels I pray your indulgence if for once
in my life I depart from my habits and
instead of fighting at once and keeping
silence talk first and fight afterwards
or not at all you as my friends will do
me the honor to listen to me Senor
tsukino as my enemy will do himself the
honor to hearken a young man and one who
has never yet taken part in a serious
combat he has exhibited his
conscientious conviction of the Justice
of his views and proved his valor and
daring by bearding a master offense who
in 15 years has never failed to kill his
man as a skilled swordsman I should feel
myself a murderer indeed where I take
upon my soul his blood in haste the
Senor is young the wine has passed
rather freely we are heated I say
earnestly let no man interrupt me that
if Senor or tsukino tomorrow in cool
daylight chooses to reiterate his words
I shall take them as a deadly insult and
shall challenge meet and slay him
without compunction
if on the other hand after I have told
my story he does not repeat his
accusations
I shall regard them all of them as not
merely withdrawn but his things never
said at all
Senor tsukino has called me a murderer
because I killed in a duel his kinsman
general della Rabaul de that was more
than 15 years ago and it was my first
formal duel so far from being a seasoned
fighter who butchered a feeble and
heartbroken old man I was then a boy
very raw and to a great extent
unpracticed
pitted against a cool dexterous and
envenom adversary in the many encounters
through which I have since passed
I recall not one which taxed me more
severely or in which I ran a greater
risk in fact the general would assuredly
have killed me
had he not chosen to fight with a sword
a perfect mate of my own which I knew
and recognized a sword the sight of
which converted me from an excited lad
into a being strung far beyond the reach
of any personal or paltry emotions a
thing all muscle nerve and will
perfectly coordinated an infallible
supernaturally accurate incarnation of
unhurried predestined at vengeance we
met in the meadow outside of the river
gate our seconds are all alive men of
unimpeachable integrity Nobles of the
loftiest traditions of the most
honorable lineage there were other
witnesses of the fight which was
scrupulously fair and which I won by
mere force of right and justice
I believe that when I have had my say
all of you and signore tsukino not least
will admit that I had just caused more
than just cause for any vengeance upon
the general that to treat him as a man
of honor and meet him sword the sword
was a condescension upon my part so far
from having forced him to meet me his
challenge to me was simultaneous with
mine to him signore tsukino has
insinuated what if he were ever to put
into words no signore hear me out you
may then say what you please
I should resent far more bitterly than
the epithet of murderer you will all
recall the sudden and lamented death of
signora delle ribald
more than two years after that of her
husband you will all remember that she
the most beautiful woman of our city who
was mourned by unsuccessful suitors
beyond any count left behind her
reputation for saintliness such as few
women have ever attained I had indeed
seen this in Europe before my combat
with her husband but I say solemnly that
until the carnival ball
I had never spoken to her then until the
morning after just before the duel I had
not known whom I so admired I admit that
he challenged me upon her account but
his jealousy was as insensate as the
spleen that drove him whose household
had escaped loss to press an imaginary
grievance upon me whose house was most
desolate of all upon a morning of
general sorrow and desolation if the
story of my grievance all too weak a
word against him has never before been
told by me it is not because I have any
reason to be ashamed of it
but rather chiefly that I was not
willing to Smerch the name of Delarue
balda with a tale of villainy so cynical
and after the custom of our family I
reserved everything involving penitence
or repentance for my confessor you shall
judge whether I am right in confessing
to you all
I shall detain you but a few moments
longer without penitence I cannot speak
of my brother
Ettore at the thought of him I am
convicted of ingratitude that most
universal most unforgivable of the sins
of youth I failed to appreciate my
brother a touré he was to me not merely
a beloved comrade he not only more than
filled for me the place of the father I
had lost but also of the mother I had
never known his tenderness was as
exquisite as his precepts were wise his
concern Universal his care constant I
loved him
loved him with the ardent adoration of
an unproved boy for a young handsome
accomplished Cavalier who is and does
all that the boy longs to be in do yet
although he stinted me and nothing
fulfilled for me all my reasonable
desires granted most of my wishes humour
my whims and bore with my moods
some malignant fiber of my heart drove
me into perpetual opposition to him his
solicitude worked me for with a boy's
folly I mistook stubbornness for
resolution recklessness for valor and
self assertion for independence I
misconstrued supervision as espionage
resenting it I began by evading
perfectly natural questions as to my
whereabouts and doings from that I grew
into a contemptible habit of petty and
unnecessary concealment as to my
outgoings in comings and occupations he
bore this patiently not showing any
change of his affectionate and kindly
bearing presently my perversity drove me
to run counter to his wishes and first
one thing and then another because he
had advised me to cultivate certain to
my associates I drew off from them
because he had warned me against others
I made cronies of them although I liked
them little or not at all I felt myself
manlier for this sort of folly I
consorted with persons of dubious
character or manifestly beneath me
resorted to quarters of the town I
should have avoided when I should have
been diverting and improving myself in
the best company possible for a young
Cavalier of our part of the world
I was roistering by no means enjoying it
with fellows I heartily despised I lost
much money gaming yet Ettore refilled my
purse without chiding me inwards his
manner conveying the just dissipation I
would not heed I came home many times so
late or so early that I found our Porter
difficult to wake and more than once was
nearly compelled to find shelter
elsewhere
sometimes I returned so disordered that
I shrank from ascending the grand
staircase and slunk around the courtyard
under the galleries to the servitor
stair I became habituated to low taverns
across the river where I naturally
became involved in wine room quarrels
and street brawls I flattered myself
that I comported myself well in these
senseless melees I dealt some shrewd
wounds and came off unscathed I felt all
the man the man of pleasure
then one night I was entrapped I never
realized how in a street fight with
several rough fleurs one of my comrades
fell and the rest fled and I was left
alone my back to a barred door facing
several blades which I barely kept off
when a tall man appeared behind my
assailants fell upon them without
warning and promptly beat them off after
the sound of their fleeing feet had died
away in the alleys I found myself face
to face with Ettore wearing a cap
without a feather and a plain brown
cloak he asked only you are not wounded
not a scratch I replied we will walk
together if you do not object he said
which way are you going home
I answered as we traverse the crooked
streets cross the bridge and made our
way home he kept silence at first and
then led me into some light gossipy talk
making no remark upon my silly fool
hardiness nor saying anything relative
to his sudden appearance or my rescue
I should have been touched by his
solicitude but with a boy's folly
instead of being overwhelmed with
gratitude to him for having saved my
life I was merely indignant and his
having followed me and watched over me
and furious at the thought that he had
felt that I who aspired to be
redoubtable might be as I was too
headstrong to confess I had been in
native assistance after this adventure
my perversity was aggravated I took the
most sedulous precautions for my own
hurt doing all I could to preclude the
possibility of Vittorio's ever again
being able to protect me from any
possible consequences of the dangers
into which I needlessly thrust myself
throughout the carnival time i fairly
lived away from home mostly and this
with a Tory's full knowledge at the
Palazzo for de cello with the wild Jim
Bautista and his wild her brother
Lorenzo I took perverse care that a
torres should not be able to recognize
me changing my dress often and wearing a
variety of masks throughout the carnival
I had been hoping to encounter a lady
whom I had first seen the previous
autumn whom I had caught sight of but
twice during winter whom I had watched
for in vain at the Cathedral and in the
search for him I had fruitlessly haunted
every Church in the city
it had so happened that on each of the
three times I had seen her I was alone
my descriptions had been unrecognizable
to those of my friends whom I asked to
enlighten me when I had described her to
a Tory he had maddened me by saying that
he knew well who the lady was but
declined to tell me advising me to think
no more of her as her husband was
devoted to her and a spleen full
dangerous man I spurned his advice but
my fevered efforts won me no success I
had no clue to her and even during the
delirium of the carnival time I had
sighted no one whom I could take for her
this failure diminished my enjoyment of
the week of revelry but I had at least
the satisfaction that I had not seen a
Tory no sense of his presence of his
hovering influence dimmed the glow of my
delight and feeling myself my own master
and perfectly able to take care of
myself in getting a discretes
as I did and getting out of them as I
might untrammeled on the night of the
great ball I was dressed as a troubadour
and was very proud of my becoming
costume no sooner had Lorenzo and I
entered the theatre then I saw the Lady
of my dreams
she wore a very narrow mask no more than
an excuse for a mask and was dressed in
fanciful garb the significance of which
I did not try to guess but with the
effect of which I was enraptured she was
with a very young man and after a word
with Lorenzo using the freedom of the
festal time we accosted them
Lorenzo engaged the attention of her
escort while I gained possession of the
lady I may say that we spent the evening
together dancing countless dances
partaking of refreshments strolling
about or seated on one or another of the
benches and the corridors or lodges so
engrossed was I that it was only
occasionally that I remembered to look
about for a tour a I never saw him nor
any figure at all suggesting his but
each time I looked among the crowd the
party color brightness of which was
accentuated by a liberal sprinkling of
Cavaliers and black dominoes all alike
slender youthful and tall I saw
somewhere one figure that as it were
stood out among the rest a tallish spare
man of erect carriage stiff bearing and
in a way not at all suggestive of youth
most absurdly and unbecomingly habited
as a buffoon not after the manner of our
theater but in the French fashion all in
white with a tight-fitting camp and a
full false face whitened with flour a
loose white blouse with huge white
buttons big as biscuits loose wide white
trousers and white slippers with white
rosettes this costume odd enough on a
young and plump figure had an uncanny
effect preposterous Lee hung about the
leanness of an elderly in frigid form it
was so unpleasantly weird that more than
once my gaze dwelt on it for an instant
before it returned to peering through my
dear comrades mask at the half revealed
wonders of her dazzling eyes our
conversation was very innocent witty we
thought delightful we felt it was near
the unmasking time when as we gave
ourselves to the intoxication of one of
the last dances I heard a Torres voice
whisper in my ear
take care do not go home alone
you have been three hours with the wife
of the most jealous man alive I turned
my head and as well as I could in
whirling through the whirling crowd I
looked about for a tour a I did not
catch sight of him nor any costume such
as he might be likely to wear I saw only
the everlasting party colored world the
iterated black dominoes the inevitable
misfit zany at the end of the dance the
youth whom Lorenzo had removed for me
claimed my partner so peremptorily that
I could not but resign her and she
addressing him as cousin went off with
him they had scarcely more than
disappeared when as I stood leaning
against a pilaster gazing across the
press of dancers who thronged the floor
at the dazzling parties which crowded
every box of the seven tears a woman's
shriek filled the hall the next instant
came the cry of fire and almost before
the boxes opposite me emptied the blaze
ran across the ceiling I took no part in
the madman ik which ensued I stood
petrified as did a few others and
recovered my senses only when the
billows of smoke rolled to the floor
then from under dropping masses of
blazing decorations through doors
empties save for the trampled shapes of
dead or in
sensible victims of the rush I made my
way from the auditorium how I so made my
way out and by which door I do not know
the spectacle of the trampled women so
sickened me that I Marvel I ever escaped
at all for at the sight of a corpse not
of my own making
I have always turned I confess utterly a
coward to gaze at a man dead by my sword
does not disturb me I see in it only the
evidence that heavens justice has made
use of my hand to give a scoundrel his
deserts but a glimpse of a dead body
that of one not slain by me makes my
head swim my eyes dazzle my sinews
loosen my knees knocked together before
such a corpse I am I may apply to myself
what no other man would venture to hint
no better than a craven therefore I
shall never know how I came out of that
furnace I was delirious with horror a
mere animal driven by the primitive
instinct of the dread of fire the
corridors and passageways were almost as
full of smoke as the theatre itself and
it seemed to me more aflame
I dare not venture to say how many
stairways I seem to find ablaze the rush
of the fire drove me in frantic flight
hither and thither through several
narrow doors and for down every stair I
saw climbing flames up more than one
stair I realized that I was quite out of
the theater and on an upper floor of one
or the other of the long disused
deserted palazzos which flanked it I
could not guess which and whichever it
might be it was certainly as much on
fire as the theatre I recall rushing
through room after room all filled with
smoke often turning back finding no
outlet and no way down several times I
scrambled over heaps of what seemed to
be old stage scenery once I stumbled and
fell jammed in a forest two broken
lathes and scantling's I do not know how
I reached the window at which I finally
found myself nor where I was joined by
that sinister figure in the white
clown's dress which I had remarked so
often during the dancing I was first
aware of him beside me when I pushed
vainly against the shut lattices of the
window and it was his strength not mine
before which they gave way
not opening on their hinges but carrying
with them they're crazy rotten frames
wrenched loose from the stonework of the
window and falling all together with a
splintering smash upon the pavement
below the noise of their crash struck
our ears while our eyesight was yet
stunned by the impact of the hot
brilliance with which as the dislodged
woodwork left the window aperture clear
we were flooded diving upward as it were
from the smoky obscurity of the interior
into an intense Ruby glare we both
scrambled upon the sill there was no
balcony outside we were looking into a
courtyard so filled with Crimson
radiance that not only were the walls
opposite us bathed in an intense light
but the dark corners were penetrated by
a weird carmine tinted glow even in the
deepest shadows there was not a human
being in sight the court was deserted it
was of considerable size paved with big
square blocks a black and white stone I
could make out on the side opposite us
the opening of a wagon archway yawning
like a black throat no arcades flanked
the courtyard and every window I could
see was shuttered fast there were six
storeys of Windows and we were at one of
the fifth story the roof cornice beetle
debuff us and roofs above the court were
silhouetted against the inflamed sky and
overhead poured the vast inverted
cataract of sparks which streamed up
from the Holocaust we had not yet
escaped
we spoke no word he stood upon the left
side of the window I upon the right my
loot I had of course thrown away my mask
I had on no longer I had lost both sword
in point yard my whole belt was gone
I had nothing in my hands which were
torn and bleeding the buffoon had a
naked dagger in his right hand a piece
of rope in his left he leaned over and
scrutinized the outlook as I did we were
a frightful distance above the pavement
and even had we been lower dropping to
the pavement would have been certain
destruction for precisely beneath us was
a long narrow area about a yard wide and
how deep I could not guess constructed
to let light into some cellar the coping
along its edge where the pavement ceased
showed as a line of dull light and the
appalling illumination
there were no balconies to the windows
below us or to any of those immediately
on the right or left of them about
halfway down the face of the wall from
just below the left of the window in
which we were to the corner of the
courtyard on that side ran a broad stone
cornice wide enough for a lean man once
standing upon it to walk along it
without holding on to anything about
halfway to the corner of the court a
metal rain spout ran down making a
conspicuous elbow over the jutting stone
shelf once said his feet upon this
cornice either of us was sure to escape
the end of it was not precisely below
the left side of our window but a little
to the left all this I took in in a
moment so apparently did the other man
there were many Flambeau brackets
projecting from the walls of the
courtyard there was one beside each
lower corner of our window the buffoon
took his dagger in his teeth kneeled
down reached over and fastened one end
of his rope to the flambeaux socket he
did not hurry but made sure of his knots
then he dropped the rope and holding to
the bracket with his left hand shook the
rope in two undulations with his right
peering down to describe its end its end
was all of 10 feet above the level of
the cornice too far for a man holding
the extreme end of it to set his feet
upon the cornice top to jump for that
cornice or to drop upon it from even a
yard above it would have meant the
certainty of going down to be dashed to
pieces on the cruel flagstones below the
buffoon pulled up the rope and stood up
his dagger still between his teeth
projecting from under the false face
which it thrust away from his own and
through the eye holes of which I seemed
to feel his eyes fixed upon me
we could hear above the roar of the fire
the confused hubbub of shouts from the
crowds which thronged the square and the
streets round about I had called for
help when first I reached the sill but
my bawling lost in the steady deep
rumbling note of the fire and in the
confusion of voices beyond one no
response
now I yelled again screamed shrieked but
no one heard the buffoon echoed my out
cries but not as if assisting them not
as if hoping against hope for rescue not
as if like myself merely giving way to
terror and despair
but rather with derisive mockery and his
rallying hellos I felt totally helpless
if I were to escape at all it would be
through him yet I felt him as an
inimical presence and feared him almost
more than the fire behind us he stood
with the Rope bunched inside his fingers
it seemed to me nervously nodding and
unknotting it then he let most of it
goes slack a coil of a loop or two
swinging back and forth in his left hand
his face toward me and his eyes I felt
steadily on me the tiny threads of lazy
smoke that had been faltering out of the
window under the lintel increased from a
thin trickle to a continuous stream
through the door of the room behind us
was visible a faint blush of blurred
brownish light as I looked at it I saw
the door darkened suddenly a man rushed
through it incredibly alive out of the
throttling reek crossed the room and a
bound and leaped upon the sill between
us he was all in black black cap black
mask black Domino black hose and his
sword in a black scabbard so Swift was
his rush so impetuously did he leap that
I wondered whether he had meant to set
foot on the windowsill or had expected
to land on a balcony outside as it was
he planted his feet fairly on the sill
but just missed pitching forward into
space he toppled bent double and saved
himself only by touching the outer sill
with the outstretched fingers of his
tense arm at this instant as the masked
black Domino rocked unsteadily head and
shoulders into the outer air the Zaini
flung the noose for it was by no means a
snarl of rope but a cunningly knotted
slip noose which he had held inside his
clothes left hand over the newcomers
head and with one lightning movement
half dragged half hurled him from the
cell in the air the victims spread out
arms legs and cloak like a huge bat his
hands Wynn milled wildly searching for
the rope and failed to touch it for a
horrid instant as the Rope checked its
headlong dive the inverted body gave a
jolted Bob upward before it turned then
it lurched over the hands making one
last clutch for the rope and again
missing the Cora drew up straight as a
rapier blade and held the body was
violently and convulsively agitated once
or twice and its sword toss
the upturned scabbard struck the corner
of the cornice with a sharp clang
bounded up flashing in the red glare and
shot down a long line of light to the
pavement its owner's corpse arrived
sinuously and then merely gyrated limply
at the end of the rope
its feet were not much more than a man's
height above the cornice my abomination
of the sight unnerved me so that my
impulse to hurl myself upon the murderer
was swallowed up in a physical sickness
in which I nearly fell from the sill as
I clung to the stone jamb the malignant
white shape dagger in hand addressed me
sir I know who you are
I was about to piece my rope with your
carcass since this intruding stranger
has spared me the necessity and since
the Rope is now long enough to be useful
I offered you the courtesy of the first
opportunity to descend speechless with
horror and loathing i tottered a
helpless jelly against the jamb he stood
his long dagger in his right hand
eyeing me through his whitened mask ah
he went on you hesitate you can pass me
easily descend by the bracket the Rope
the cornice and the rain spout you will
not then you will pardon me if I leave
you you will find it warm here before
long
nevertheless if this place is more to
your liking than the street I do not
dispute your right of choice a good
night to you I'm tempted indeed to put
this dagger into you before I go but I
reflect that though you do not look it
you might have the strength and slight
to avoid my thrust and perhaps even
throw me down I shall not risk it if you
overcome your panic and are not burned
here or killed by falling if in short
you get down alive and get home you
shall hear from me in the morning he
leaned over tore off and threw away his
false face and revealed to me a
countenance I did not then recognize
next his dagger in his teeth he dived
for the bracket caught it with both
hands swung himself off into space
gripped the Rope first with one hand
then with both went down it stood on the
dead man's shoulders let himself down
the Rope till he clasped the corpse
wriggled down it embracing it closed
dislodging the cloak which sailed down
the air like some huge bird
settled upon the pavement far out into
the court near the sword the escaping
villain finally gripped one ankle of the
corpse with each hand swung himself and
all above him gently sideways until his
feet found the cornice steadied himself
by the feet of the corpse let go and
stood up edged gingerly along the
cornice to the rain spout and slid down
it smoothly once on the pavement he
leaped into the air clapping his hands
and crowing scampered briskly across the
court stopped to pick up his victim's
cloak and sword turned to glance up at
me waved me a derisive farewell and
after a hideous caper of joy vanished
into the black throat of the wagon
archway running like a fiend my eyes
came back to the dangling body revolving
slowly now its mask hung beside the neck
and the back of the head was toward me I
felt myself doomed I knew I could never
summon up resolution to escape by that
road in fact I am sure that from losing
my hold as I actually later descended
and being dashed to pieces on the
pitiless stones nothing saved me but the
set fixed purpose of vengeance which
made me not a man but an automaton I
looked behind me the glare of the fire
was bright through the smoke dense
volumes of which poured out of the
window above my head and the heat of
which I could feel at that instant came
a terrific dragon crash a brief darkness
and an agonized wail of groaning shouts
the roof of the theatre had fallen in
the smoke sucked back through the window
above me and momentarily I felt cool air
on my face the next instant the volume
and intensity of the light redoubled as
the overarching stream of sparks became
a firmament of fire the court grew
bright to the deepest darkest corner
Eddie's of air swept past me the corpse
swung round its mask blew away wholly
hideously bowed the head was the chin
driven into the bosom but I knew the
face of my brother
Ettore
you